[Música]
una extraña criatura y recorre las
calles de tu luz desde el 2018 con sus
12 metros de altura exterior el
minotauro es un gigante de madera y
acero que se volvió uno de los emblemas
de la ciudad lossada
un éxito que se debe en gran medida a su
creador quien hizo del espacio público
su terreno de juego en toulouse pero
también en nantes con las máquinas de la
isla
estos gigantes traen de vuelta a nuestra
mirada de niños cuando tenemos 3 años y
que les llegamos a las rodillas a
nuestros padres vivimos en un mundo de
gigantes y este es el periodo de nuestra
vida con mayor apertura a las emociones
fabricando gigantes logramos
desencadenar dicho proceso
volvemos a hacer niños
un lenguaje artístico posible gracias a
una mecánica extraordinaria un
exoesqueleto 100 made in francia
[Música]
dirigido por cinco maquinistas que hacen
mover los brazos el torso y la cabeza
del gigante el minotauro fascina e
impresiona vienen de todas las regiones
para verlo otros lo observan desde el
balcón los vecinos están encantados
desde que está aquí nos conocemos en mi
amiga
veo la reacción de la gente gusta o no
gusta cada quien con sus gustos
pero no se puede ser insensible la
modernidad a la a la investigación la
creatividad de lo que se ve este
escudo
a pesar de su modernidad y su tamaño
fuera de lo común el minotauro es más
sensible de lo que parece el desgaste
causado por el paso del tiempo y los
elementos son marc a su epidermis hoy
los artistas de la máquina revisan las
arterias y las tripas de esta hermosa
mecánica
trataré de subir poco a poco hasta
llegar al torso y ver sus pulmones
es el segundo chequeo al minotauro desde
su nacimiento una intervención
particular para todos muchos
participaron en su construcción
conscientes de dar nacimiento a una
máquina extraordinaria hoy en día
familiar un amigo frente al que se
sienten muy pequeños
es como si fuésemos un pequeño que
sube adentro de un humano
como si fuésemos una pequeña hormiga
caminando sobre las mangas en efecto no
tengo la impresión de ver el cabo de un
vehículo cuando trabajó en el minotauro
se oculta a cada órgano y los
especialistas intervienen cuando surge
una patología en este momento estoy
haciendo reumatología cambiando las
rótulas de las partículas y más
porque los meniscos
están cansados después de caminar tanto
en la pista de los gigantes
otros escrutan y analizan con minucia la
piel del minotauro
sanarán sus heridas o por el contrario
perdurarán algunas cicatrices
su piel reacciona con el tiempo por lo
sube la polución que hay alrededor
por ejemplo en algunos lugares se ven
grietas
ello me hace pensar en manchas de vejez
en cierta forma
o la live está vivo
una vez renovado hay que probar todas
las funciones del gigante
[Música]
es una marioneta grande
soy marionetista y en este caso somos
más pequeños que la marioneta y
tiene una velocidad distinta a la
nuestra porque son unos gatos
hidráulicos los que activan los
movimientos de los brazos las manos la
boca y
desde el momento en que hacemos un
movimiento y el momento del envío a la
máquina hay un lapso y
el movimiento es más lento porque yo soy
ligera
pero la máquina es pesada hay que
imaginarse como una máquina de 15 metros
de alto
el arte del movimiento puede acompañar
la fabricación de la ciudad y
desencadenar algo natural la ciudad no
solo es algo serio para ir del lugar al
trabajo y el trabajo al lugar de consumo
olvidamos hacerle un lugar a una máquina
un poco rara ya los animales mecánicos
oa la escultura lo que hace que la vida
sea un poco más divertida y más animada
el alma de asterio en el minotauro es el
trabajo tras bambalinas de los
maquinistas y los equipos de creadores
que transforman cotidianamente esta
marioneta gigante en una verdadera obra
de arte
[Música]